MarieAnne Thérèse Ombline gonau Montbrun
est née en 1755 à Saint-Paul elle épouse
en
1770 Henri Paulin pasanon des bassins un
cousin éloigné de cette union naissent
13 enfants de 1771 à
1797 neuf d'entre eux survivent et
occuperont des situations élevées tant
sur l'île Bour bon qu'en France l'une de
ses filles Mélanie épouse en
1799 le comte de villel ministre sous
Charles X et Louis XI après la mort de
son mari en 1800 cette riche
propriétaire met à profit les conseils
de ses fils Joseph et Charles pour se
maintenir pendant 46 ans à la tête de
son habitation de Saint-Gilles les haut
et orienter la production vers la
culture de la canne à sucre catholique
praticante elle fait édifier sur sa
propriété é de saint-gill une chapelle
domestique à l'architecture originale
lieu de culte destiné aux gens résidants
dans les haut de Saint-Paul et à ses
nombreux esclaves femme intelligente et
maîtresse femme son esprit éclairé lui
vaut durant la première moitié du 19e
siècle le surnom de seconde
[Musique]
Providence aujourd'hui demeure une
légende noire de Madame des bassins qui
prend son origine à la fin du 19e siècle
mais se surtout dans les années
1970 elle fait d'elle un être cruel
dépourvu de toute humanité et dont l'âme
est condamnée à expier ses crimes au
fond du volcan de la Fournaise dans
l'oratorio Ombline ou le volcan à
l'envers œuvre composée en
1998 le poète Boris gamaleya évoque sa
présence elle arrive ne vous cachez plus
dans l'autre dormez rêvez elle a perdu
sa blancheur la folie de ses absolus
elle tombe et s'élève champ de songe
pour nos peuples usinié et sur nos
blessures silence de vérité
bleu